* Stechmücke summt. *
Hm. Aua.
"Scare Crow" hat gefragt,
wie man sich am effektivsten
gegen Mückenstiche schützen kann.
Sehr gute Frage.
Erlaube mir
ein bisschen auszuholen.
Wie "Scare Crow" richtig schreibt,
sind nur weibliche Mücken
fiese Blutsauger.
Dabei ernähren sich Stechmücken,
wie viele andere Insekten,
eigentlich von Pflanzennektar
und Fruchtsäften.
Nur wenn die Weibchen
gerade ihre Eier produzieren,
brauchen sie Blut,
um diese zu entwickeln.
Ihr müsst kurz stark sein,
denn es wird gleich brutal eklig,
wenn ich euch zeige,
was Mücken genau mit uns machen.
Das, Freunde der Sonne,
ist ein Mückenrüssel,
wie er in eurem Gewebe herumwühlt,
bis er eure Blutgefäße gefunden hat
und dann darin herumsaugt.
* Schrille Geigen
aus Hitchcocks "Pyscho" *
Wua!
"Stich" beschreibt
eigentlich noch den besten Teil
der ganzen Katastrophe.
Nach dem Stich wühlt und
saugt die Mücke im Schnitt 4 Minuten.
4 Minuten hiervon!
Aber das ist noch nicht genug
für dieses Sch... (piep) -Vieh.
Mücken haben die Unverschämtheit
in unser Blut zu spucken.
Geht's noch?
Der Grund für diese Respektlosigkeit
ist folgender:
Unsere Blutgefäße
sind auch nicht dumm.
Wenn jemand kommt
und in ihnen herumstochert,
gerinnt das Blut,
damit es nicht überall hinläuft.
Deswegen injiziert
die Mücke über ihren Speichel
Antikoagulanzien,
also Blutverdünnungsmittel.
Damit sie in Ruhe in dir
herumstochern und saugen kann,
ohne festzustecken.
* schrille Geigentöne *
Das ist alles sehr eklig,
aber das Stechen und Saugen
ist nicht das eigentliche Problem.
Sondern dass die meisten Menschen
allergisch gegen Mückenspucke sind.
Was passiert:
Unser Immunsystem bekommt Panik.
Wenn unser Körper mit einem
Allergen konfrontiert wird,
produziert er Histamin.
Dieses kleine, unscheinbare Molekül
ist das eigentliche Problem
des Mücken-Dramas,
weil es Entzündungsreaktionen
hervorruft.
Das Blut, zusammen mit
vielen Weißen Blutkörperchen
strömt zur
"Gefahrenstelle" Mückenstich.
Die Folgen sind Rötungen,
Schwellungen und Jucken.
Uah!
Es wäre alles sehr nett,
wenn Mückenstiche gefährlich wären.
Sind sie aber nicht.
Worunter wir letztendlich leiden,
ist eine völlige Überreaktion
unseres Immunsystems,
das uns unbedingt beschützen möchte.
Es sei denn, die Mücke überträgt
gefährliche Krankheiten.
Aber auch
da hilft eine Entzündungsreaktion
nicht wirklich weiter.
Toll, danke Immunsystem.
Wie kann man sich
vor Mückenstichen schützen?
Ihr müsst noch mal stark sein:
Es ist praktisch unmöglich,
den Viechern zu entgehen.
Die Dinger können dich anhand
des CO2, das du ausatmest,
aus einer Entfernung
von 50 m aufspüren.
Die effektivste Maßnahme gegen
Mücken wäre also: nicht mehr atmen.
Kann ich nicht empfehlen.
Auch zu Anti-Mückensprays
machte die Forschung
eine deprimierende Entdeckung:
DEET ist der
wirksamste Antimückenschutz,
weil sein Geruch Mücken abstößt.
Allerdings haben Forscher beobachtet,
dass immer mehr Mücken
resistent dagegen werden.
Ich habe noch einen Downer für euch:
Abends beim Lüften
das Licht auszumachen,
damit die Mücken nicht reinkommen,
soll auch nicht besonders
viel helfen, behaupten Forscher.
Da sich Mücken, im Gegensatz
zu vielen anderen Insekten,
weniger am Licht orientieren,
sondern mehr an Geruch und Wärme. Ah!
Am Ende hilft nur,
die Haut mit möglichst
langen Klamotten zu bedecken,
Mückengitter anzubringen oder unter
einem Moskitonetz zu schlafen.
Ich jedenfalls benutze Insektenspray,
denn es gibt noch genug Mücken,
gegen die das wirksam ist. Chemie!
Schönschlau.
Untertitel:
ARD Text im Auftrag von Funk (2017)
Wenn die Folge zu deprimierend war,
ich hätte noch ein paar Tipps.
Zwar nicht gegen Mückenstiche,
sondern wie man damit umgeht,
wenn man schon welche hat:
Ich habe nach dem Urlaub 18 Stück.
Wie viele habt ihr?
Falls euch das noch interessiert,
schreibt es
in die Kommentare mit euren Fragen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Bleibt sicher.